[Music]
ready to rock yeah so Chris held back in
the house last time I saw you we were
sitting in a hotel room not dissimilar
from what we always do this in hotel
rooms we now we're in Santa Monica last
time I saw you we were in Stockholm
fresh off our to the experience I think
that's right you've got it down I know
and I wore the special t-shirt for you
today look at that somebody a fan sent
this to me
custom-made on the front are the GPS
coordinates for the start of the race
and on the back or the finish line I
down there so anyway I'm gonna have to
get you one of these yeah I'll see if I
can hit her up for a second one well you
sent me something really awesome
that are you got it framed pic tried you
got it over the weekend I was sick last
week so so out of it uh-huh so here I am
saying thank you right here you sent me
an amazing sort of picture frame full of
pictures from the race the map of the
race and signed it and so on it's
awesome well I appreciate that but I
can't take full credit for that because
that was made by a fan who made two of
those right oh and one for me and I sent
that wise you well whoever that is thank
you yeah thank you the name escapes me
at the moment but I will find out okay I
will properly think yes and I needed to
send an email in the show notes but yeah
I was pretty cool right it is really
cool so we're back here for another
edition of Coach's Corner and we have
some cool stuff to talk about we're
gonna talk about offseason training
we're heading into the winter months how
do you stay in thews e astok about your
fitness how do you stay fresh and
connected mentally physically and
emotionally with with your with your
athletic journey athletic goals yeah I
mean they seem so far away right now and
it's October basically one of the last
days of October and in order to project
out what April and May will feel like it
feels
so far away right now and staying
motivated the days are getting shorter
the weather's changing
and so it's hard and so however we can
help communicate what we're doing as
well because we're sort of in-between
events and we don't really know what
we're doing next and that's part of it
it's as a community understanding we
need to stay motivated right I think the
first thing is we have to acknowledge
that we're in Southern California and
and and I'll be the first to admit how
soft that has made me when the days get
shorter and it's just a little bit
colder in the morning and it gets darker
a little bit earlier my motivation wanes
pretty quick like it's just it's just
hard to get up out of bed when it's dark
out and it's 40 plus degrees so I can't
even imagine you know staring down the
barrel of you know a snowy morning and
so you know sub-zero temperatures like a
lot of people are gonna be contending
with in the not-too-distant future so
it's tough it's really hard to maintain
that level of motivation when the sun's
not shining and the weather's not bright
yeah and it's important to also give
yourself a little bit of a break in
those times because it's about
consistency
it's not about overdoing it you don't
want to stay super focused as always
telling an athlete earlier today it's
about being 80% there you know take that
20% edge off that you're super focused
on whether it's nutrition or how you're
sleeping and how you're training and all
the attention to detail that you look
for instead be consistent stay connected
and have a focused outcome for that
month and that next month so that you're
still progressing somewhat but you're
not literally on it every day and yeah
one of the things that happens to me
after a big event typically is I want
nothing to do with working out for a
little while and I think part of that's
healthy like you need a break you know
mentally as much as physically so
putting some time and distance between
you know that intense period of time I
think is appropriate but but then it
makes it that much harder to get back
into it I had
different experience after Sweden I
remained enthusiastic about being fit
because it had been five years since I
had competed and I and it really did
take me a long time to get back into
form and I was like I'm not letting this
go again it took too long to climb back
up that ladder and yet nonetheless and I
and I went right back you know I took
maybe out on ten days of doing close to
nothing but then got back into a
consistent rhythm with the workouts that
you were sending me but I've been far
from perfect like I've you know but
traveling and I miss here and there but
it's a different reaction to missing a
workout like what I'm not because I'm
not signed up for anything right now and
I'm not quite sure what I'm going to be
doing next although that may change
pretty soon to be like okay what's oh I
missed it like no big deal as opposed to
you know eight weeks out from Oh till Oh
thinking oh man you know I can't I can't
miss a day so it's a different response
to not being perfect it is and I mean
there's two reactions to after an
immersive event like an attila right
well you would want to stay away from it
for a little bit and just want to give
your body and your mind a break but many
people come back from the whether it's
an ironman and ultra something like go
till oh and they're so motivated and
they're so excited because it was such
an incredible impactful experience that
they want to train again right away and
that's when your mind and your body sort
of separate you're motivated but your
body's not yet and you have to give
yourself some time to get those two and
sync again and recovery and the proper
fueling to get those two back on the
same railroad tracks takes a few weeks
and a lot of people try to start up
again too quickly and they fizzle out
and that's when the motivation really
gets hurt because then your body is
disconnected from your motivation right
and then in four or five weeks from now
you really go off the rails so you have
to manage yourself very carefully after
the event knowing I got a reward myself
with some downtime and I've got to
reward my body with some downtime
otherwise in three four or five weeks
from now I'm going to fizzle out even
worse but it's tricky because you want
to harness that motivation when you have
it because momentum is so important and
if you just let go of
and say we'll revisit this in eight
weeks and then when eight weeks goes by
you know that that that motivation has
been eclipsed with you know the Sun
setting too soon now and the cold the
cold mornings and cold night it's the
best time to formulate your plan though
in those weeks where the motivation is
high but you don't have to train it you
can start writing out your plan you can
start working into all I want to do
strength I want to stay connected like
this you even came back and said I'm
missing a bunch of type of strength work
that I felt was missing or I really want
to start incorporating this so together
with your coach or with me in this case
we start formulating a plan or you sort
of give me homework to come back and say
all right this is what we're gonna do
the next six weeks and then as the big
training comes back in you'll have that
platform to work off of right but it's a
great time for that yeah in in in the
wake of Oh till oh that was one thing
that was very clear to me is that I was
lacking a significant amount of
functional strength and that that event
required so much of it the scrambling on
all fours and the bending down and the
you know sort of hauling yourself up
these rocks and all of that took a huge
toll on me and I was not prepared for
that nor did I train for it and it made
me realize how much I've been
overlooking that critical aspect of what
it means to be truly fit right yeah
because I just want to run and got on
trails and bike and as important as I
know it is to be you know sound in a
whole-body context and strong I just was
not attending to that and so you've put
me on over the last several weeks a
pretty challenging it looks on paper it
looks easy it looks so easy yes
challenging routine functional body
exercises that are as simple as like
planks and air squats and some lunges
and things like that without any weights
you know you've just started giving me a
little a few kettleball exercises and
things like that I'm doing with very low
weight and it's amazing how sore it
makes me and how how like sort of
crushing it is like just doing a series
of air squats and I can't walk for like
three days and that's part of the 5-year
rebuild we're on right we got you sort
of fit again
in aerobic capacity and with the runs
that you've been doing and now we're
adding in more cycling but now we're
going deeper we're peeling that onion
back a little bit more and working on
this functional strength and so on the
other thing is it's nice for you is that
I'm doing that on purpose because you're
traveling you can technically do a lot
of this on in any hotel gym yeah and you
don't even need the gym for 90 percent
of what you're giving me you could just
do it in any you know 4 foot by 4 foot
space yeah yeah we want to stay away
from that though you don't start working
out hotel rooms has you're on the road
too much we want to get you outside a
little bit more and it takes a lot to
get me in the gym I'm not a gym rat but
the winter months that's the time right
yes is the time where you can create
that that strength base yeah and it's a
it's a little bit of variety too because
you're doing something different you're
activating different muscles you're
seeing different people you're in a
different environment it does help a lot
of people with their motivation actually
it puts them where other people are and
they still you feed off of that and so
getting to the gym two three times a
week on these darker months is a great
time to sort of re-engage also with the
social aspect of working out and then
mix in some cycling mixing some running
mixing some swimming is great with
regards to functional strength as you've
been doing that I bet you if you go in
the pool afterwards the first 1,500 or
2,000 they're just yeah swimming with
thugs and but it just connects you to
everything that you just activated and
most of these if not all of these
exercises are really really pivot around
core strength yes fundamentally and I
can tell you from experience I know what
it feels like in the pool running and on
the bike when my core is strong versus
when it's not I don't think that it was
very strong from this past season but
when it is strong like if you even if
you're just doing 15 minutes you know
four times a week or three times a week
and you're doing that consistently over
five six seven eight weeks you could
feel the difference
yeah the strength in your stroke like
just your métier able just from your
body position all the way down the line
it is incredibly noticeable yeah you
should and a big part whether it's
swimming biking or
what separates our work muscles legs in
the case of running and biking with how
our form is upper-body is all the core
and if we can attach the two working
parts of our bodies with better
stability and better strength it's
incredible how long that carries us and
an avoids injury and then swimming of
course we're working upper body but we
want to keep things sort of smooth with
the lower body with our hips falling or
sneaking through the water and if you
have a strong core you can keep
alignment as well and so it all starts
from the middle before you do all the
exercises of swim bike and run right but
we often overlook that people without a
lot of experience in swimming believe or
you know sort of mistakenly believe that
you're generating power from your arms
and your shoulders and your lats some
extent you are but it's really coming
from the core mm-hmm you know and and
it's not just injury prevention and
technique it's that you're able to
maintain your form when you start to
fatigue lawyer yeah your way to maintain
your running form you're able to
generate power from your your core when
you're climbing on a bike and certainly
in the pool yeah it's huge
and it's it's it's again it's the anchor
of everything we do it starts at the
center and if it's strong there you can
start working on actually improving your
running form a lot of people focus on
their shoes or on their foot placement
because their back hurts or so on but
then we take a closer look and you
notice they have no core and no
stability coming from the core so the
load of the impact of the ground let's
say running 40 times your body weight is
all being lost in the middle because
nothing is stabilizing it right I know
what I hate doing it so much yeah it's
the worst right and it's a lot so hard
eats where we are currently so it's a
lot of repetition and you like another
set and another set and they're set so
so if somebody's listening to this and
their time crunched but they want maybe
three or four or five core exercises
that they can work into their routine
what are at the top of your list well I
really like those founders that we've
been doing lately
well if you look up a standing founder
or kneeling founder on the on Google or
on the internet you'll find that pretty
quickly but it aligns your entire body
and it requires you to maintain your
core structure
I like those rows that we do with from a
sit-up perspective type where you're
extending your legs and sort of rolling
your arms at the same time while
maintaining your core because again it
keeps the whole chain activated and
movement while you're doing core is
really important because you want to get
all those support muscles and
stabilizers going as well so just
sitting in one spot doing situps
while that's good you want to create
more movement and rotation around that
do again really create whether it's from
the four pack to the six pack the six
pack to the eight pack I mean my
daughter's a gymnast and watching her do
some of the core exercise it's
ridiculous I couldn't even come close to
keeping up with her haha
yeah my experience is that you start
really slow like I start with doing less
than you advised because I want to nail
the technique I guess my form has to be
perfect that comes above everything else
and if I'm doing it consistently I know
that I'll build up quickly like it can't
the strength comes quick when you're
doing it consistently but you got to
make sure that your technique is dialed
in and you're not just jerking yourself
around just say that you did that many
reps and if you're doing it properly you
don't need to do that much if you
haven't been doing it you know before
and you're gonna feel the hurt because I
mean some of those bridges that we do
holding them for 30 seconds is the
longest 30 seconds of the entire work
now I know and the body counting wrong
something's wrong yeah is crazy and
you're you you sent me the workout so
I'm looking at it on my phone on
training peaks and I'm at the gym and
like I don't even know what these words
mean like Jane Fonda's and like what are
these crazy kettleball I don't even
there's there's weird terminology so I'm
like I go I see that and I'm like okay
now I got to go to YouTube and like
watch a guy do this to figure out what
I'm supposed to do so it's taking me
like three times as long to do it
because I'm trying to learn as I go
that's how new to this I am like but
it's so important I'm already seeing the
results and it's an investment because
we're gonna do six to eight weeks of
this
and then we're gonna have a platform we
go off of from there where we'll use
more kettlebells medicine balls will do
our stretch cords and things like that
to keep getting you stronger from the
inside out
and the important thing also and this is
harder for the time crunched athlete but
to then do the motions that you're
focused on for your discipline for your
sport afterwards on a tired body to
focus on clean form light running for
example high cadence cycling with an
easy gear just to feel everything
engaged and fatigued from the strength
that you just did from the stability
that you just didn't notice wow there's
my stomach muscles as part of my cycling
form right so these gym exercises these
core exercises they never come after the
swim bike run workout they always go
before always always and in an ideal
world you find another 15 30 minutes
after to swim bike or run or row or
whatever your discipline is that you're
getting ready for mm-hmm I like this
idea of kind of adhering to the
circadian rhythms of your body and the
seasons yeah there's a lot of wisdom in
that
you know nutritionally and just in terms
of behavior habits it's something I
think we've moved too far away from in
our culture because you're right you
can't there's no way you can maintain
that level of focus and motivation
year-round and the last thing you want
is to come into July or August or
whatever your big race is burned out
well it's also sustainability with
regards to your life family your career
right you can't continue to maintain
this singular focus on one thing while
the other stuff keeps sitting on the
backburner and or you keep pushing not
negatively away and I'm not saying that
in a and as if people are completely
overlooking it but but you're just
trying to balance all three very
carefully and sometimes things do take
bigger priority and this is the time of
year to exhale and accept that and me
have fun with it I tell a lot of
athletes this is the time of year you
cycle where you've passed roads before
and you've been curious I wonder what's
up that road or that you take your
family to hide
on some of the runs the far places that
you've run to right in order to just
sort of include and an exhale a little
bit so that when the hard months come
and the motivation is not there but you
really need to push through you have a
way to look back and go you know what I
gave back then I backed off a bit now
it's time to hunker down mm-hmm I just
have the experience the other day
because when I go out for a trail run I
have my four or five favorite ones that
I like to go to because I know exactly
what to expect I know where where they
lead and how long it's gonna take
measurable there for training but
there's so many other trails around me
that I've never visited because I don't
wanna when I have a key workout I'm
trying to nail I don't want to hit a
trail I've never been on before and find
out it ends like 200 meters into the run
or something like that like I don't want
to take that risk
so just the other day I went down pretty
close to my house this place called
paramount ranch all these trails down
there and it goes through this old
western town where they film TV shows
and I was like I cannot believe I've
never been here before like it's
literally down the street because I
don't want to make that bargain but yes
it was like this is the time to do it
it's an easy run I'll just go and
explore and how it's a rewarding process
at this time of year
yeah and in general as the motivation
gets lower and things get harder and the
events are so far off and we don't know
what to focus on besides those
short-term goals that we said at the end
of the month it's staying connected with
your body that you get to know yourself
well enough that you can say you know
what sure I fatigue quicker or I'm not
as powerful but I'm not far off I'm
healthy I'm connected to my body and
once the warmer days come or once I have
an event I can start building the plan
and focusing back on that but for now
I'm staying connected mmm
that's the important piece one of the
things that I bought up against or
experienced in the off season is and
this is when I'm not working with you is
decision fatigue right okay there's no
key race coming up there's nothing
specific that I'm training for so for
people who aren't working intimately
with a coach you know what is your
suggestion in terms of
how they approach these months these
weeks when there isn't a lot of
structure to avoid that pitfall of
waking out well it do I do this do I do
that like that just doesn't work for me
yeah and then you're like you're just
walking around like burning all this
energy going well I could run but if I
do that then I'm gonna be late for this
meeting so maybe I'll do that tomorrow
and you spin this cycle that it's just
so much easier when I open up training
Peaks and that workout is there it's
like yeah that's what I'm doing today
like I'm not there's no debate about it
the easy answer is always to say we'll
work on your limiters at this time of
year right but that requires even more
motivation right because you don't enjoy
it as much so if you don't feel like
doing that or if you just don't want to
motivate yourself currently to work on
your limiters at least say with your
strengths do the things you enjoy
because that's important you're doing
this as a hobby it's not a job so do it
because you enjoy it and then there's a
lot of cross training opportunities from
skiing so cross-country skiing skate
skiing doing different events and trying
that you know trail hiking even right
with with weight on and things like that
Rocking there's all kinds of different
events in the meantime that people can
do that keeps them aerobic ly connected
what is your opinion on CrossFit
CrossFit I love it actually a lot of
people always surprised when I when they
hear me say that and that is because a
good six eight-week cycle of CrossFit is
incredibly impactful I've never done it
somebody's knocking at the door yeah
should I go answer it hold on never been
asked for ice before well it's because
you weren't recording a podcast yes
there's nothing right yeah right that's
interesting so you're you're you're
you're a fan and sort of cross I've
never done CrossFit well I think the
format needs to be an eight-week cycles
6-week cycles as they build and progress
you through a good strong cycle but then
the challenge that I have with CrossFit
and a lot of them have gotten a lot
better with this because they're aware
of that and that is then to phase off
for three four five weeks so that your
body can absorb the work and the stress
it went through to get stronger and then
you know three four weeks of maintenance
real light or load even going into some
endurance stuff that we do and then go
back for another six eight week
now there's memberships and the gyms are
in structured like that that way you
come in we're gonna start a six-week
program for you but there is plenty of
knowledge and experience and great
trainers out there who can set that up
for you yeah I think it I think it it's
important that whoever's running in the
CrossFit box that you go to knows what
they're talking about
and I think you also have to know
yourself because it's it's easy to get
caught up in the you know the enthusiasm
of the crowd and the support which is
amazing and that's the biggest part
there we were we're in a sport that is
very alone right and so if you have an
opportunity to motivate yourself with
other athletes in a gym or in a box or
with a master swim program or anything
where you can just be around other
people and having fun and get to know
people it's huge because we spend so
many hours out there alone during the
season this is the time of year to start
building those friendships and those
support groups that get you out there
right or to the gym I think just starts
slow though oh yeah I don't want to get
hurt yes good it's got to be pretty easy
to get hurt in CrossFit yeah there's
usually a PT place very close to every
profit gym and there's your cards on the
wall everywhere uh-huh yeah you know so
what else about the offseason do we need
to keep in mind well you want to
understand that also speaking of me here
when you get sick you have to listen to
your body
write your own medicine no no I just got
I just got done with being sick and I'm
surprised how shelled it left me I even
jumped back into the pool and I'm like I
was out of the pool for a week how bad
can it be I would say about 1500 yards
in I started losing my energy and all of
a sudden I was swimming practically
backwards I di
get out of the swim practice the other
day and go to the bathroom where was the
last time you did that it's been years
I've actually done the excuse of I sure
I need to go to the bathroom I need to
take a breather so it really surprised
me it really knocked me down but I also
needed to recognize like you need to
take a couple of days and really go easy
and not expect a jump right back in
because it could leave me either sick
again or injured mm-hmm what is your
sort of take on the experience that we
had in Sweden now that some months have
passed like looking back on that
experience well it was obviously amazing
I had a blast doing it with you now
knowing it and understanding it better
and we said this from the very beginning
of course there's things that we would
want to train differently and apply
differently so I think that's the main
takeaway I would love to go back and
really get our asses kicked right we
were really just snot flying out of our
nose going that hard the whole way and I
think we're totally capable of that and
be fun so from that perspective but I'm
not also that competitive about it
anymore um a lot of people have asked me
well do you want to go back do you want
to is this the thing now and that's
exactly the answer I don't want to give
because sure you can go back every year
and try to improve and sort of do the
Ironman thing again but I've been saying
I feel like I have a few more years left
to really do some wacky adventures
before I gotta start slowing down right
or my body will start telling me to slow
down
and so Otello taught me there's so many
adventures out there that we can still
attack and have fun with and experience
and become smarter better deeper
athletes from that I want to explore
those though you should I mean it would
be fun to go back knowing what we
learned and preparing a little bit
better
you know then at least speaking for
myself than I did last year but it's not
like oh I have to do that you know I
don't feel that we're still not gonna
win yeah sure right you know I mean it
like so we're still participating of
course we want to be respectable but
again there's so much adventure out
there to be found and to experience and
immerse ourselves into that it just
opened the door of exciting new
opportunities I think and this is just
my personal opinion I think you need to
do Altermatt yeah you've got you got to
do it and you only have I mean you could
probably do it when you're 55 and win it
but I think you've got a couple years
right now where you're in the position
to walk into that race and do some
damage I mean you you could certainly
win that race
I know it's a huge time commitment to
prepare for something like that but as
somebody who's done that race and
obviously you're the person who
shepherded me through that it's a really
extraordinary beautiful event and I
think you would love it and I think you
would crush it yeah well if you'll be my
crew I'll crew for ya yeah there's no
question about it I would crew for you
guys it's one of those adventures that I
have on the 2018 idea list I'm putting
in for Norseman mmm which is next week
the general entry so that should be fun
if I do get in go back to Scandinavia
and cold water cold weather but the
interesting thing very it would fit on a
progression even towards Ultraman if the
back end of next year becomes that yeah
because I think you still the way it
stands right now you still have to do
another Ultraman to go to the Hawaii
Ultraman yeah well they also have
wildcard entries oh they do they do okay
I wasn't sure if they still they do that
yeah yeah what else is on that bucket
list mm there's a couple of um super
long ultra runs that I've been also
introduced to from my athletes so
anything in the Alps Italy and things
like that were three four day five day
multistage ultra running events
that's starting to become interesting
because again it just makes me Rockies
is that well that's a that's a team
thing in the US but in Europe you have a
bunch of on Alps yeah exactly
Alps version I've gotten into with a few
athletes with marathon des Sables now
and while the desert isn't sort of my
thing and I like the heat I think
there's other adventures that I would
prefer multi-day mm-hmm but it's also
learning again the nutrition and the
fuelling from what you have to pack
yourself and how you start working your
body down to understanding exactly what
it needs for so many hours a day and
then the sleep and the recovery I mean
diving into it with these athletes has
been great it's such a negative venture
to be a part of have you trained
athletes for everybody else before yeah
you have once about eight years ago and
I was a rookie with it and he was - and
he finished and he had a great
experience but it's more now having some
people who are competitive in it and
it's gonna be fun
yeah that's a really cool yeah someday
maybe okay well I have a little
adventure that's possibly on the horizon
but I'm not the guy who I might be doing
this with as has sworn me to secrecy for
the time being but yeah I'm inching
closer towards a possible event in the
new year that I'm pretty excited about
and and since I sort of know what you're
talking about I think what's really
interesting about it again it's a new
learning experience it puts you into
that growth place where you will again
have a huge leap forward into what your
understanding of your body of your mind
and your environment is and that'll be
just again such a cool cool adventure
yeah
it's about is different from Otello as
it possibly could be and I'm just gonna
leave it at that for right now well
report back soon on whether it's
or not yeah that'll be a different
coaches corner yes very very different
cool man well I think you know in
thinking about how we enter into the
winter months and stay fresh and stay
engaged and excited speaking from my own
personal experience as somebody who kind
of got you know a little bit out of
shape over the last couple of years and
then clawed my way back it's so much
more important to be consistent than it
is to put in the huge days yes and as we
go into these darker months to just
remain to remain engaged on some level
so that you're doing something every day
or if not every day most days so that
you're connected to your fitness and if
that's just a half an hour or 15 minutes
or 45 minutes that's fine because the
consistent application of that will is
much more important than oh I didn't do
the super long run or the this or that
you know the impressive workout that
looks good on Strava yeah and recognize
80% of you doing it as serious as a
hundred percent of you is already really
really good at these times of the year
and don't be so hard on yourself right
sure you don't want to slack off but
understand well there's an edge that I
can take off there's a place I can
balance and feel really good connected
not unfit and still moving forward and
set those short-term goals those are key
sort of saying at the end of October I
want to achieve this right at the end of
November I would like to still achieve
this and especially as we go into the
holidays the hard thing there is there's
so much distraction there's so many
other things going on that make those
goals a little bit simpler but say by
January one I want to ride a hundred
miles at this time of year something
like that or do a hundred push-ups in
five minutes something I think that's
wise advice what you don't want to do is
be that guy or woman who wakes up on
January 1st or January 2nd feeling like
because you've just slacked off
completely and let the whole thing go
and then go okay what am I gonna do now
like you just woke up from some crazy
you know food coma fever dream so yeah
start just laying those little pricks
now yep and even if you're not perfect
you're not looking for perfection
through the holidays you're looking to
just remain somewhat connected somewhat
consistent because we can rebuild it you
don't want to be too hard on your just
touch with yes exactly we can rebuild it
but if we're taking eight weeks off it
becomes challenging mm-hmm
what else do we need to know
Thanksgiving is creeping up no no I
don't think yeah ultraman's creep enough
that's right yeah I haven't even been
paying attention I don't even know the
reason I don't know I know that the
field is up it's pretty impressive I
thought a couple weeks ago because I had
an athlete pointed out to me but yeah
this is again just stay healthy stay
motivated take the edge off and be
positive I think that's a good place to
end it yeah for a brief this might be
our shortest Coach's Corner yeah but
it's good right just a corner all right
well will you come back soon yeah do
this once we know and know what we're
preparing for we don't need to we
probably will buy them now yeah but
continue with the strength continue
working on little things that you know
we're niggles last year and again we
know you can run we know you can cycle
you we know you can swim it's more about
now working from the inside out it's
been really good to be back on the bike
I read the other day and I was like I
actually like I can actually ride up
this hill you feel like the strength
right way yeah yeah I felt it right away
and it felt really good to be back on a
bike and engaged with it because it had
been so long all right you forget how
how much fun it is yeah so that's good
I'm glad you enjoy it yeah right now I
am cool awesome man uh if you're if
you're digging on Chris as always at AI
MP coach on on Twitter and then AI MP
coaching comm and the weekly Word
podcast on iTunes and all good stuff man
all right only athletes you coaching
right now this is the time of year where
you reapply people yeah but it's been
pretty steady that I keep my stable of
50 athletes that's what
spend four years now just right around
there good deal man
awesome alright until next time thank
you peace plants training cool
[Music]